hi welcome to the neuroscience virtually
been 2017 my name is dr. kantha and I
will talk about my research here in
Mexico the title is optimal cut point
for coffee or linea to predict the
occurrence of hemorrhagic
cerebrovascular events in patients 18 26
to set to 60 years of age who receive
care in a second level hospital of the
mexican institute of social security in
the state of sonora so as a background
we're going to talk about
cerebrovascular diseases in general and
one of the things is about the
background so see where basket disease
is an important public health problems
you know and secondly is the second
global cause of death 4.9 million cases
occur in middle-income countries and 1.2
million percent in low-income nations by
2030 its incidence will increase by
forty four percent so according to the
latest data presented by mexico's
secretary of health showing our country
the mortality rate of cerebral vascular
disease has continued to increase since
2000 particularly in people below the
age of 65 during 2007 from the total
income in public hospitals one percent
was attributed to cerebrovascular
disease in the northern state of sonora
during 2008 there were seven hundred and
nine deaths due to cerebrovascular
disease complications so as you may see
Sonora is one of the states of the
country with the highest mortality rate
with an incidence of 28.5 per 100,000
inhabitants a cv a figure above the
national average because of its
pathology so the purpose of our study
was to establish an optimal cut point
for culturally Nia to predict the
occurrence of haemorrhagic cerebral
vascular event in patients 18 to 60
years of age the method that we used
actually was to assess cholesterol
levels in 53 vascular
patients haemorrhage even tskinnak that
were admitted at the emergency
department in general hospital number
fourteen of the mexican institute of
social security we determine whether the
cholesterol levels in this cerebral
vascular disease patients were less than
180 milligrams per deciliter and we
probably check some articles from Japan
in which they were looking for
cardiovascular diseases but they found
additionally that in the Japan of the
pre-war era the diet was low in fat and
they have a lot of cases of the river
vascular diseases especially
haemorrhagic and when they were
conquered and after the war and they
reconstructed Japan the diet became
Western what's a nice so they increased
the cardiovascular diseases invert heart
attacks and actually they saw that the
incidence of hemorrhagic to baskin
ceases lower after all those years so
they were looking for heart attacks so
they merrily seen this just as a little
observation and they didn't studied
further so here we're trying to make a
study that follows that line that they
just observed but we're trying to do
something better we're trying to make
assumptions and specially if there's a
point in which there's a praise place
position to serve to haemorrhagic
cerebrovascular disease for by
statistical purposes we use the IBM spss
statistics and net [ __ ] software so as
you can imagine the results that we have
the rupture analysis of the collateral
levels as predictors for hemorrhagic
through vascular disease found an area
under the curve of points77 with a
conference interval of ninety-five
percent or juden index was point 68 with
a conference in confidence interval of
ninety-five percent determining an
optimal cut point value of less or equal
161 milligrams per deciliter so the
confidence interval was ninety-five
percent
with a level of certain cultural between
149 and 161 a cut-off point set up less
than 161 milligrams per deciliter
determines a sensitivity and specificity
of 84 with a conference interval of
ninety-five percent so as you can see in
the next graphics the ROC curve which
actually show us because too lenient and
the incidence of hemorrhagic and silver
basket disease especially in the terms
of sensitivity sensitivity and
specificity as you can see it all
combines at the eighty-four percent so
the next graph shows a comparison
between the hemorrhagic silver basket
disease which is a line in blue calling
blue burst of the Hispanic ischemic has
fever battle disease which is in red and
actually can see how the cholesterol
levels reach a point in which for the
haemorrhagic fever basket disease we
find a conic off point of 161 and for
cholesterol goes higher higher than 200
so as you can see the area under the
curve it's point 77 and the t is very
significant has a very high significance
because it's less than point zero zero
one so they cut cut off pound value of
the zune cholesterol you can see for the
haemorrhagic server vascular card is 161
and for systemic SuperBass the disease
is actually around 180 to 200 and more
higher so in conclusion in a patient
with a cerebrovascular disease earth
study shows that a cholesterol level 11
161 milligrams per deciliter it's able
to determine the presence of hemorrhagic
to vascular disease with high levels of
sensitivity and specificity so we
propose that in an scenarios with
resources that are limited and the
completion of a definite image
study may be delayed cholesterol level
should be used as a supporting
diagnostic cash or study is a pioneer in
implementation in the Mexican population
and the American continent so the better
understanding of this nature of disease
is actually very encouraging for future
generations from future research so we
can understand the disease and make in
the future better medical interventions
to avoid mortality and disability thank
you for your attention